>> Tucker: WHEN HE SPOKE
TODAY, HE DID NOT GET TO EXPLAIN
WHY A FEW WEEKS AGO HE WAS
TELLING US THAT IT WOULD LOOK
NOTHING LIKE SAIGON.
>> THE TALIBAN IS NOT THE
NORTH VIETNAMESE ARMY.
THEY ARE NOT REMOTELY COMPARABLE
IN TERMS OF CAPABILITY.
THERE IS NO CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
YOU SEE PEOPLE LIFTED OFF THE
ROOF OF AN EMBASSY OF THE
UNITED STATES FROM AFGHANISTAN.
IT IS NOT AT ALL COMPARABLE.
>> Tucker: BRIT HUME IS OUR
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST, WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE HIM HERE,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
SO HOW DO YOU ASSESS THE
POLITICS OF THIS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION?
>> I THINK THIS IS A STAIN,
UNMISTAKABLE THE VIEWPOINTS
ACROSS THE BOARD OF THIS
EVACUATION OPERATION, THE LAST
PIECE OF THE PULLOUT HAVE BEEN
UNIFORMLY THE SAME, THERE IS A
DISASTER.
IT WAS HORRIBLY PLANNED,
MISBEGOTTEN, AND THE DECISION TO
DO IT LIKE THIS WAS WORST OF ALL
AND YOU ARE HEARING FROM ALL
CORNERS NOW AND I THINK IF
PEOPLE LOOK AT THESE IMAGES
STAMPED IN PEOPLE'S MINDS, A
PATHETIC STAIN ON THAT TARMAC
TODAY WHERE PEOPLE WERE CHASING
THAT AIRPLANE, PEOPLE DON'T
FORGET THAT AND IT WILL BE A
STAIN ON JOE BIDEN AND HIS
RECORD THAT WILL ENDURE.
THE BEST THING HE HAS GOING FOR
HIM RIGHT NOW IS PROBABLY THE
FACT THAT THE AMOUNT OF
REPORTING WE GOT MAY BE VERY
LIMITED.
WE MAY NOT KNOW THE EXTENT OF
ATROCITIES BEING COMMITTED OVER
THE SUBJUGATION OF WOMEN IN ALL
THE THINGS.
>> Tucker: IT'S POSSIBLE THEY
WILL MAKE THEIR PEOPLE WEAR
MASKS AND COVER THEIR FACES.
>> THAT'S POSSIBLE.
>> Tucker: I'VE BEEN
FRUSTRATED FOR A LONG TIME THAT
WE ARE STILL THERE AND THAT'S MY
PERSONAL VIEW AND I STILL FEEL
THAT WAY.
SO I'M GLAD WE'VE LEFT BUT THERE
HAS TO BE SOME NONHUMILIATING,
NONDISASTROUS WAY TO LEAD.
>> THE THING THAT BIDEN RATHER
CLEVERLY TALKED ABOUT IS TALKED
ABOUT THE DECISION TO WITHDRAW.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING
ALL ALONG TIME AGO, WE'VE BEEN
GRADUALLY WITHDRAWING FOR YEARS
AND THE QUESTION WAS WHEN THE
FINAL PULLOUT OF THE FINAL WOULD
BE THERE.
THE ADMISSION OF NATION-BUILDING
EVERYONE SEEMS TO AGREE WITH HAS
BEEN ABANDONED FOR YEARS.
I THINK ARE YOU GOING TO NATION
BUILD WITH 2500 TROOPS?
WE WERE THERE AS MILITARY
SUPPORT FOR THE AFGHAN FORCES
WHICH SEEM TO BE MOTIVATED, VERY
MUCH MOTIVATED BY HER PRESENCE
THERE AND DESPITE ALL THE
CRITICISM THAT BIDEN LEVELED
AFTER TODAY, THEY LOST TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SOLDIERS FIGHTING
THE TALIBAN.
SO THERE IS THAT.
BUT THIS QUESTION IN THIS ISSUE
IS ALL ABOUT HOW YOU EXECUTE THE
FINAL PULLOUT AND THIS WAS
UNMISTAKABLY HIDEOUSLY BOTCHED.
YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAY WE HAVE A
HANDLE ON THIS, WE KNOW.
AND I WASN'T AS EXCITED ABOUT IT
AND WE MAY HAVE A DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT THAT BUT THE EXECUTION OF
THIS PIECE OF IT -- THAT'S WHAT
HE INHERITED, HE INHERITED A
DRAWN DOWN FORCE ABOUT TO BE
REMOVED, HIS JOB WAS TO REMOVE
IT SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY,
RIGHT?
AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF HIS
DECISION-MAKING ABOUT HOW TO DO
THAT OR WHAT WE SAW TODAY AND
YESTERDAY.
THIS IS ON HIM.
THIS PIECE OF IT IS ON HIM.
>> Tucker: I WONDER IF IT WILL
BE RECORDED THAT WAY.
>> AT THIS POINT SOMEWHAT TO MY
SURPRISE, WE HAVE SEEN IT
RECORDED THAT WAY AND I'VE SEEN
PEOPLE SAY HE IS TRYING TO
CHANGE THE SUBJECT WITH THE
WITHDRAWN SOLON BUT THIS I
THINK.
>> Tucker: I DON'T SEE A